[Music]
he went from farming maple syrup
to philosophy in oxford and has now
become one of silicon valley's most
famous investors reid hoffman has always
been fascinated by the intersection of
technology
and human networking from creating his
own undergraduate major at stanford
to helping found paypal with peter thiel
and elon musk
hoffman then created the professional
networking site linkedin
and made big bets on facebook and airbnb
now some of the same questions that have
driven him through his life
are front and center finding the best
balance between social media and human
interaction
and just how much is too much technology
on this edition of bloomberg big
decisions reed hoffman
reed hoffman welcome to bloomberg big
decisions it's great to be here
blitzscaling new book out you've
co-authored
what is the thing that drove you to
blitzscaling what really
made you think in this way so
it's the blitz scale against the
practice we do in silicon valley
it's the grow from us back of the
envelope idea
to a globally relevant company a
transformational company of industries
the thing that got me to writing the
book and doing the podcast
the masters of scale and all these
things was that the secret that people
say about silicon valley is still the
startup story they say
silicon valley four million people all
in half of the nasdaq
why is that people say well it's because
we have all these startups and some of
these startups succeed
and that's true but it's true in 100
plus areas in the world now
what's important is the way that we get
this to massive scale very quickly
it's the airbnbs the ubers the facebooks
the linkedins
and this set of techniques about how you
go to market how you
hire talent how you scale the company
what
business models you create those are the
things that allow silicon valley to do
this
when does it make sense to blitzkill and
when doesn't it when is it stupid to
blitzcale
blitz scaling essentially is
prioritizing speed
over efficiency in an environment of
uncertainty
now you'd say in an environment of
uncertainty wouldn't you rather just
reduce uncertainty
well frequently it's driven by
competition in this hyper-connected
world
competition comes from everywhere and so
the choice of saying well
actually the first to scale is the
business that wins
the first to scale is the business that
actually essentially sets all the rules
then getting the scale really matters so
it's primarily driven by competition
when is it reckless actually to
blitzcale so i think it's reckless when
you don't have the competition right
like you actually don't have the
competitive
uh lens if you feel that
the set of things about well will i be
able to pull this together
in a macro business like for example if
you don't have the ingredients to think
about
how will the mature business look like
it's not to say you have exactly all
figured out
but if you for example blitzscale a
business where the unit economics
simply won't work you couldn't get them
to work well then you're going to
actually create this big crater
so those may be risks that you're going
to take
but you try not to take them unless you
need to
and and on the course of blitz scaling
when do you need to go back and say okay
now we have to worry about those
efficiencies yes
so usually it's okay we
we think we have this important new area
we wanted to get to size so for example
airbnb we want to get it so that this is
the
new way this new domain of how you
travel
how you experience local markets and
we're going to get it into this
into this in this massive shape by the
way airbnb is still in its split scaling
stage
but as it gets established as it becomes
a understood category
then what you start doing is shifting
from speed of growth
to efficiency to well we're still
acquiring lots of customers we're still
doing it
but how do we really make the product
a lot more polished how do we make our
business operations
a lot more effective in terms of capital
allocation take your blitz scaling
analysis and apply it to a couple of
real world situations
what about twitter has it sort of is it
in that
phase of more mature business where it
needs to be more efficient and improve
its product
here's one of the paradoxes about making
the decisions in blitzscaling
so twitter next major face of growth or
efficiency
well it depends on what ideas you have
for the next major face of growth it's
not just kind of like a
scientific measurement it's do we have
ideas that we can play against
now part of why you're measuring your
investment thesis is
well you're trying to measure are my
ideas good what should i invest in them
or should i try to operate towards
efficiency so if you have a good idea
about how to
take twitter to the next level you may
still be in a blitz scaling phase
or you may move again to a blood scaling
phase but if you don't
then you start focusing on efficiency
does that mean
if you are in this very successful high
growth tech company
you want to be looking for other
essentially arrows in your equivalent i
mean we see this with facebook
they didn't just rely on facebook google
did the same thing
yes i actually think all of the great
tech companies and all the tech
companies are saying how do we build
these amazing tech products in the
future
are actually looking for the next major
areas to add in either build themselves
or acquire or acquire and combine and
grow
and i think that's the central pattern
by which you know the
the the major companies 10 years from
now
are the ones that are doing that today
so so as you look at it
that would suggest facebook is on the
right track as far as you can tell from
the outside
uh google is on the right track although
i think they're very concerned about
facebook
uh right amazon you think that would be
right
absolutely but then do you raise
questions in your mind about a snap
about a twitter
well i think those are the existential
challenges for those companies
and i think that the management teams
can figure them out i mean both
you know evan spiegel's a very good
product inventor jack dorsey is a good
product inventor
i wouldn't put it past them to figure
out what the right thing is
but that is the challenge in front of
the business which raises a further
question
as you go from a potential transition
from this geometric growth
and bit scaling into becoming more
efficient improving your product
do you need to change your people i
think the same team can actually do both
you see that in a lot of great companies
you see that
with jeff bezos and amazon you see that
at facebook you see that
at a number of these companies where
they they balance the two together
and and so for example uh even you know
kind of
part of what's amazing about sachin
nadella is you know
renovation and microsoft is their blitz
scaling azure
in this so you know it's always a
possibility to do this amazing new thing
in a company that has already been you
know
very successful in other things you have
a great analogy in your book
about a pirate turning into admirable
navy
do we have a pirate at tesla or do we
have an admiral
navy um we might have a pirate admiral
right uh he's uh obviously
extraordinarily good at
uh taking this very hard problem of
building a new car company from scratch
with a new software platform on top of
it of doing both the luxury end
and the and the mainstream end and
actually in fact doing more than anyone
would expect he could do
there's all the admiral side on the
other hand he occasionally also of
course
you know makes pirate declarations um
and you know i think the reason he's
doing it he's trying to change the
status quo he's trying to say look we
should
focus on five years and ten years versus
the now and that
the people kind of bringing him back to
like short sellers other kind of things
makes him irritated
i think focusing on the five or ten
years is the thing that he's doing and
we should all want him to be successful
there
so let's talk about the tech world and
how it interacts with the rest of the
world
what are the obligations the moral
obligations if you will
of the tech world at this point as it's
become a much more mature business a
very big business
to the rest of us so it's one of the
chapters we have in the book blitz
scaling which is what is responsible
blitz scaling
and i think the thing that the tech
industry has been learning
has been oh well we're not just the
challenges we're not just the disruptors
we're now becoming part of the
infrastructure
the social infrastructure the logistics
infrastructure
and as we become part of that
infrastructure and we get to the scale
of it
our responsibilities change we can't
just say hey trust us we're going to
build new products
we have to be transparent we have to be
disclosed we have to be in dialogue with
society
and we have to be more careful about
which risks we take
because we have a greater impact with
that does technology have
a brand problem we love facebook or
twitter whatever
social media we're on at the same time
there are some real questions being
raised now can we trust
these people with our information with
our data with our patterns
or not is there a branding problem here
i think there's
definitely a brand challenge at the
moment but i think it's more a little
bit like kind of teenage years as we
grow i think it's recoverable
like if you ask a lot of people do they
love their iphone do they love their
their their technology service the
answer is generally yes
but they now need to under like we as
the tech industry now i need to say
but people also want to feel safe and
they don't feel safe if it's a lot of
things about like
cyber hacking or my my information was
hacked and so we now need
to have a higher level of of standard of
safety there
and that needs to be added into the way
we communicate with people so you spend
a lot of time with
the leaders of taco in silicon valley
and elsewhere
uh do they get it i think they're
learning so i
if you said do they have it 100 right
now not yet but i think they're
on a learning curve that's moving pretty
fast so i think they will absolutely get
there
and what is the role potentially of
government regulation let's talk about
u.s government regulation
is there going to be regulation should
there be regulation it's very possible
that
some regulation could be good it's a lot
easier to do a lot of damage
to the tech industry to our position of
tech industry in the world to the
invention of the future to this lead in
this industry that we have
than it is to do help so we i think we
should be very careful
so i think where the dialogue should be
right now is not as much should we
regulate should we not regulate
as much as what should the target be
like for example what do we want out of
the social infrastructure of the social
media companies
what do we want on the handling of data
what do we want
on the new evolution of these
technological platforms ai and so forth
and what are some of the kind of
guidelines that we say look we want
you guys as companies telling us about
these issues
reporting on them and we want you to be
more transparent about them
so that we can see how we need to push
you and whether or not the push is a
dialogue whether the push is an inquiry
or whether that pushes a regulation and
i think that's where the conversation
needs to be
so if there were constructive regulation
would it be on the subject of meaningful
disclosure not just disclosure but
meaningful search
so i think the question would be to
figure out well what kind of
transparency
do we think would be most helpful and
most meaningful to us
like i do think the very first thing
would be is tell us about this stuff and
if you're not being
disclosed enough then we'll make
regulation to make you disclose
and then the question is well is it for
example
data security is it an ability to have
controls over about
your understanding how your data is
being used and your buy-in to that
those probably are the zone but how do
you do that in the right kind of simple
way that also leads to
a lot of ability to innovate in the
future so as you talk with the cheryl
sandberg's of this world the mark
zuckerbergs of the world
um what is the discussion about how do
you get in front of this
instead of the appearance that you're
getting dragged kicking and screaming
i think the key thing is to show that
you're
to be transparent and disclose about
that you're investing in the things that
people care about
and by the way they are they're
investing in like for example election
integrity they're investing
in uh data security and
not just to do it but to show people
you're doing it to show people you say
i hear what your your worries are and
we're working on them and by the way it
may take us a few
iterations to learn it exactly but we
care about it
and we're investing in it and then to be
talking about that and i think they're
beginning
i think they're on path to exactly those
conversations
how does the tech industry responsibly
both participate in the chinese market
but not have the chinese government
essentially act as a sensor we're seeing
it right now with google
so
it's one of these things where each tech
company has to have its own mission
right so the mission for google is all
the world's information in your
fingertips the mission for linkedin
is economic opportunity for everyone you
know maximizing
the connection between talent
opportunity
part of i think when you're one of these
tech companies you have to say well how
does my mission
intersect at this market
and based on the intersection of that
market
we will you know kind of negotiate we'll
we'll we'll negotiate with the
governments about how to best
reach that and you do have to be
responsible to your local government
but like for example the linkedin case
china's much easier because we say okay
well
we're not about all the world
information your fingertips we're about
maximizing your economic opportunity and
so that
works well there it's more challenging
for google because the
chinese government says no no action in
fact we want to control
which information our populace sees and
that makes it more challenging for
google and i think that's
that's one of the problems they need to
sort out what can technology do to help
us with some of the big issues the
pressing issues around the globe and i'm
talking about things like climate change
education poverty inequality of income
and wealth
so many big problems
the solution is technology so i do think
the tech companies which have the
capabilities the powers the ability to
do this
should focus on this so for example in a
linkedin context it's
how do we have reskilling how do we have
constant upgrades of skills for the kind
of new jobs in industry
that's a linkedin responsibility it's a
microsoft responsibility
i think climate change is probably
best addressed through like new energy
technologies
you know new uh you know making coal
clean and so forth so
myself as an investor i've been
investing in some of the energy tech
companies
partially with the breakthrough energy
coalition that bill gates has pulled
together
i think that these ability to apply
technology to solving these fundamental
human problems
is part of the responsibility of
technologists and the tech industry so
absolutely but in some of these very
major projects you need to work together
so for example
if you're doing innovation and energy
that's actually something you usually
need public private like how does the
regulation work how does the
major infrastructure works and the
collaboration together is a much better
solution
artificial intelligence is really a race
everywhere around the world to see how
far we can get how fast
um are we in danger of falling behind
china or are we behind china already
so i don't think i think we're ahead i
think that
the depth of of decades of r
d and technology and bringing the
brightest minds from everywhere in the
world together
to work on it here ha still does give us
a lead
in artificial intelligence and other
technologies however
because the chinese are being smart and
directed and saying
we know this is where the industries of
the future will be built so we're
investing in it
well we should be doing that too let's
talk about who reed hoffman is
you study philosophy what did you take
away from your experience doing
philosophy
that applies to you today well actually
surprisingly one of the things i think
is philosophy has been more important to
me
than any background in business and the
reason is is precision of thinking
it's a thinking about human nature it's
thinking about what an investment thesis
is
and how you measure that when you're
trying to create something new something
from nothing
those kinds of tools about this thinking
about possibility thinking crisply
measuring it as a way of creating the
measurements against the investment
thesis
are all things that come back to my
philosophical training
so a great rigor in thinking at the same
time the goal of philosophy at least
when i did it was to get as precise as
you can get which means it never ends
did you have any difficulty
letting it go as it were that is to say
i don't know all the answers i still
have to make a decision right now
i think i didn't have the difficulty of
making a pragmatic decision i think the
thing that you had to learn
was that make the decision now
and then realize that you're going to
learn and you may make a different
decision
later but the way that you learned was
making the decision now
would you have been reed hoffman if you
had been born somewhere other than palo
alto
if you'd grown up somewhere other than
outside of silicon valley
well i'm one of those people who thinks
that i'm enormously lucky
right being born at the stanford
hospital being born in the u.s
uh the opportunities that that that were
presented to me
are not opportunities i would have
gotten elsewhere and we all learn from
our environments we learn from the
challenges in front of us so
i'm certain i wouldn't be this reed
hoffman i hope i would be
a different interesting reed hoffman but
the environment that i'm in
is we all should be blessed with the
opportunities that were presented and i
i feel very lucky now you've brought
back your philosophy to stanford
and you really work on an entirely new
discipline sort of interdisciplinary
way of thinking tell us about what that
is so i was the eighth person to declare
a major known as symbolic systems
which is this question about you call it
artificial intelligence you call it
cognitive science it was
that we're these kind of unique
creatures that
think and speak in languages and that's
part of how we think that's part of how
we understand the world it's part of how
we understand each other
it's part of how we coordinate discover
truth
and symbolic systems is a study of that
and what the reason i did it was because
what i was more interested in was
not just one discipline but the actual
subject
matter itself applying philosophy
applying
computer science applying linguistics
applying logic
bringing all of these things together to
understand what is humanity
you said we're unique creatures in our
ability to do that
will we remain unique creatures so
the future is always a little uncertain
we ourselves evolve i actually think the
process in which
what is humanity is actually evolving
synthetic biology
artificial intelligence cybernetics
there's all these things in
the next 50 to 100 years are actually
going to be pretty stunning
in what's possible i hope that
that humanity will be a central part of
it i i think we work to make that the
case i think
but the real question is how do we
evolve to be better versions of
ourselves
and i think that's the most central
question you started as a ceo
not a ceo not a chief strategy officer
but a ceo
i think you referred to as firefighter
in chief actually
uh how much did that influence your
subsequent career
well i was always doing strategy it's
part of the reason i wanted me in the
company but the when when peter hired
when i stepped off the board because i
was on the board when paypal was founded
and i stepped off into the company peter
wanted me to
solve the key problems and so actually
part of the co title was less
just run everything operation as much as
any major problem that i need you to
solve
go solve it and so this ranged from
uh you know kind of like okay what's our
relationship with ebay
uh how is the financial infrastructure
underlying that's going to work
what's going to be our interface with
visa and mastercard
how we're going to grow kind of what our
our
our business operations practice was
going to be you know at each of these
things peter would hand me a different
challenge
and those challenges those learnings
were central to
the entrepreneur that i became the
bifurcation it may be artificial between
operations and strategy mirrors a little
bit we were talking about philosophy
versus
making decisions uh and not everybody
can do that
we know people who are really great at
thinking not particularly good at
getting it done we know people who can
get it done
but don't really think it through how
rare is in your experience out there in
silicon valley or more generally in
business do you have somebody who can
actually
do both together i think it's relatively
rare
although i think part of the um the
thing that most people need to learn is
most people think they're better
strategists than they are and it's a
very good thing to be thinking
how do i learn to become a better
strategist i mean i myself do that
constantly
i try to learn from people i try to
learn from how to think about this
coming together strategically and then
a lot of times people think and say the
idea is all that matters and it's kind
of the
the classic thing well it's two percent
inspiration 98
perspiration you still need the
inspiration to go in the right direction
but you need to be able to execute it
well well exactly right i mean i
certainly have seen in business that
everyone wants to do strategy nobody
wants to do the blocking and tackling of
actually implementing strategy
often we don't know if the strategy was
successful or not because we never
really did it
is that something you come across
frequently well one of the good things
about entrepreneurs entrepreneurs tend
to be practical they tend to know that
they're in this
environment where they're default dead
so it's like they tend to be like what
do we accomplish today what do we
accomplish this week
now one of my favorite expressions is in
theory there is no difference in theory
and practice
and so it's that combination of theory
and practice
that is what you try to do as a
successful entrepreneur and as a
successful executive
you've had to make a lot of decisions
think back on one
that was counter-intuitive that is to
say either i didn't think it would work
and it worked beautifully to my surprise
or the reverse boy i was sure it was
right and it just blew up in my face
well i've had a bunch of both um
probably the the funniest one was uh
when
when peter thiel came to me and said hey
join the board of this thing that was
called confinity
and it was like encryption on mobile
phones and i was like oh this terrible
idea was never going to work and it
didn't by the way
and i joined principally because good
friends with peter was like look i'll
help i've been doing this
entrepreneurial thing for a few years
and
let me join forces and help and then
paypal became the inflection point in my
career and if you'd asked me when i was
joining the board would this become the
inflection point
i would have i would say no no
absolutely not the idea is not going to
work
and so that serendipity of the
the depth of connections of the people
that you work with that you live with
in your life is the kind of thing that
can lead to amazing opportunities you
just don't see
thank you so much pleasure
[Music]
you